ha
we'll go in town
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade for a rematch of
mole hammers hey guys a cheating son of
a [ __ ] decided to show his face around
mom parts again cheating cheating son is
the one every other son of a [ __ ]
decide to show his face around here
again
I decided it's time to punish him once
more in the game of Ages I'm back to win
deal with it
where'd you get me some left oh are they
there sorry do that I was gonna do I
don't think I need to know yeah pretty
good anyway I just spanked his behind
and table tongue and all that was a
different game don't bring up the
Badgers nobody knows about the Badgers
will talk anyway
maybe we should play the game shut up
I'll decide when we play this game okay
we could spend the whole goddamn episode
of the loading screen for all I care
okay well we're gonna talk about plating
that's why I'm sorry okay here we go
also I'm on the left of the camera I'm
on the right this is confused I'm blue
I'm red let's go whoa Wow
this can't start out this way I'm I wake
you thank you Oh No
oh there's a bunny hat yes exactly bunny
oh yeah whoa I remember how this goes
I'm gonna approach it calmly
and certainly yes exactly
okay not that I didn't need that okay
okay okay
I also realized when I was editing this
video there's no commentary to be found
it's just all screaming whoo like most
of my videos anyway this one in
particular is just a screen how does it
even make sense that you would well it's
just totally random
oh just not random ah yeah you're gonna
have that one no it's not random that's
not random at all okay there we go
nope okay how do you still kid I don't
know okay I gotta get one more perfect
okay come on I want to start it over
well we know we're gonna know we're
gonna start the episode hook we're
starting the episode are you showing the
last games Burgers table hungers that I
won I won the game of table tongue not
the last one we could look good write
down in the comments what you think the
game of table tongue is will give you a
mama I'm gonna watch to see how biased
all these are will give you a moment
moments over
let's do it moments over okay hello
everybody my name is water barn welcome
to mol hammers no cheating settled [ __ ]
I just want this is ash on the intro
cheating son of a [ __ ]
No decided to show his face around these
parts again and challenge me into
another game ah he's gonna give up
what he's gonna get his butt what find
me so let's play for the first time that
we have yeah second time that I just won
Fred what are this oh yeah you've won
the last game last month but this one I
like I have a chance I hate you so what
are you don't all right okay so for the
first time here we go let's gooooo you
got a good score there okay
ah Zhi Jing Zhi pass on the okay I'm so
doing that for the intro if I win this
yeah no it's okay why is it why the
words Johansen yeah it's like two times
Hey oh this the crew is so great that we
started this episode on such a high note
if I know what I mean there's no high
note here you worried not a dirty
cheater
okay maybe maybe we're gonna start the
episode again no no no no what I don't
get oh yeah oh let's go ahead
hey I'm gonna win this now I'm gonna win
it for home and country every sunta for
bed and get something for beyond come on
we need needs a new pair shoes
oh it's like the closest it's never been
in this entire game the ultra comes back
I that we're gonna choker everybody what
did I do wrong I don't know
good thing our control what do we ever
do right in these being controlled
oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to mole hammers nice the
son of a [ __ ] here decided to show his
face around my parts again in online
parts around these parts again and to
show him how bad he is at games I'm
gonna whoop his like a like I did at
table tongue oh did I say table tongue
deja vu all over again like 10 minutes
and I want every day I don't know if we
always do a long intro to war Mike you
know you know how it goes Tony the way
this is wade and if you don't know Wade
Jesus will be playing this game till
mark wins yes she's a sore loser
knowing the healer we're gonna miss the
charity stream because of the shot up no
we're not
I got this oh yeah okay I gave that to
you I took the one point on that one cuz
I planned
Oh points better than dope yeah
ah tigey oh I never know when yeah okay
so ah this is the thing about this is
clean about this
I'm way better I'm way battery way
better at this game in wait this is I
feel so bad I needed him to have one
that he could win so if I could give it
now literally oh no no no no no if I
could just I would have had a perfect
fit eh that's what I said oh yeah I
heard something else oh that is I don't
know the algorithm behind that but it's
stupid how did how did I got that ah ah
and it wasn't it like us always bunnies
in this game is the stupidest game I've
ever seen in my life
but you guys applied to ever see it cuz
we're gonna do a new intro for the next
one no that'd be TAC three and oh you
the hammer is my dank
oh yeah well yeah Thor's Hammer's mine
my ulnar yeah he could will he pitch he
can wield your penises Thor can wield
your penis is where you told me you tell
me no farts working out anyway
hello everybody my name is Marco Marmee
welcome back to bowl there no son of a
[ __ ] is what you are
I must be through this intro cuz I don't
feel like doing a Milan
oh really doing a long one oh my god oh
uh if you forgot Oh up 100 I thought
there's a picture okay
no Yuri out and stupid ah when the
perfect is sick it too early no with the
perfect stupid office door oh I'll take
that garbage I'm on recycled soul all
your garbage
oh crap
oh we're gonna helmet I got a ring
whenever you get the helmet just kids it
oh oh okay okay things are starting make
sense again what do you mean I found the
intro the helmet in okay well then oh oh
this game got interesting though it did
not this gate up yeah that's interesting
you gonna have negative points don't
tear this away from me game if you do
Heights with yeah there we go
you starting to come back in 2010 oh
yeah Josh yeah come on give us a big one
No
every 100 100 rien 101 301 well then
that one that was a plumber I was my
plumber because my stove was leaking
water true story true story I was I
turned on my dishwasher and I was
cleaning out my sink and suddenly the
sink backed up and my stove was leaking
water I'm not lying
that's it weirdest thing my stove was so
we're gonna be doing that and we are
gonna be very conscious about our
yelling yes but either way I won one you
did win one okay it's one to nothing so
far as everybody out there goes yeah we
only blame this one time before okay
yeah a month ago and I'll admit you won
that one
the cheater won those ones over there
see and let's play again so that you can
be started handily yeah oh this is nice
boom Boris Marvel Post want to know him
okay so we're moving on her a second
game that we played and I've won one
weight is not because he have to be
ridiculous if nothing at in charge every
game Joe we already did the intro this
is moving on to the second row are what
you what you so hard you don't know that
Oh
Game five walking 500 so anyway after I
won one round we decided that we're
gonna end the game there because we
wanted this to be a nice short video to
really succinctly tell um who is the
better man here so that was it we won or
I won I won this for you guys cuz I play
for the devil he plays for himself
that's why he'll never be a winner what
so I am a person of the people guys he
does not lies and slander
what do you mean slander don't say that
to me that's a dirty room playing this
with you and your daughter being racist
God you should play the things that he
says on camera let me just show you what
he said oh I dare nobody showing the
hair anyway that was more hammers I won
at in spirit that's all and didn't score
it so anyway we're all done here thanks
again everybody for watching you can
check out our original matchup of mole
hammers where I put up even less of a
fight in the description below or in the
annotations over there check out his
channel he's Lord minion seven seven
seven as always we'll see you in the
next video bye bye Leah go say a goddamn
word
- ow
I started